los abrazos derrumbaron momentáneamente
los muros fronterizos
durante apenas tres minutos ya que el
impudor abrazar a su hermana que vive
del otro lado de la frontera llevaban
tres años sin verse y mucho menos
tocarse
que los que hallamos
como ella unas 200 familias se
congregaron en la frontera que divide
méxico y eeuu para un reencuentro tan
breve como emotivo
el evento denominado abrazos no muros
permite a estos inmigrantes que viven
como indocumentados en eeuu regresar a
mexico y reencontrarse con sus seres
queridos una plataforma fue instalada
sobre el escaso caudal del río grande el
mismo que una vez cruzaron para empezar
una nueva vida
es igual una videollamada una foto no
hay como sentirse a proponerse moderna
que teme a mis hijos
el reencuentro masivo fue celebrado con
pañuelos y música también incluyó
pruebas de kobe 19 para prevenir
contagios en los últimos 7 años unas
3000 familias se han reencontrado en
este evento anual el mensaje central es
que no podemos permitir que se sigan
separando familias no importa que
gobierno sea lo han hecho hasta ahorita
lo siguen haciendo y nosotros seguiremos
haciendo este evento mientras sigan
separando familias yo eh vaivén revirtió
varias medidas que donald trump había
impuesto a los migrantes entre ellos a
los solicitantes de asilo que ahora
pueden ingresar a eeuu para continuar su
proceso migratorio en lo que va del año
más de 237 mil personas fueron detenidas
intentando cruzar la frontera la mayoría
centroamericanos que viven desigualdades
económicas y sociales en sus países
agravadas por la pandemia poniendo una
vez más el tema de la crisis migratoria
en el centro del debate político
estadounidense una crisis que lejos de
las estadísticas tiene rostro humano el
de una muy difícil separación que viven
millones de personas día a día